from Washington Peter I know history is
being made what is the history that's
being made this is a big moment for
Angela Merkel and for President Obama
this was a previously scheduled visit
for the Chancellor here to Washington it
comes now at this critical juncture in
the crisis in Ukraine and there is a
division right now between the United
States and Germany and other European
nations over exactly how to handle
Vladimir Putin going forward there is
this push within the US government
particularly members of Congress to arm
the Ukrainians and the decision made by
the president after not only this
meeting but the conversations I'm told
in Minsk as to whether or not the United
States will take that separate president
may be more reluctant than many members
of his own administration Peter define
arm the Ukrainians is this sending tanks
and guns is it bringing in our troops is
it doing it through NATO what does that
phrase mean it can mean a whole host of
things Tom and that's why the president
has some more flexibility here a lot of
people are talking for example about
anti-tank weapons lethal defensive
assistance the kind of stuff that can
kill Ukrainian separatists and perhaps
even the Russians who are backing them
as well it would be a major escalation
on the part of the United States to give
some of that material to the Ukrainians
but the reality is is that the president
could decide to give more modest arms at
this point and maybe dole it out over
time escalate it just as the if the
crisis would escalate further as well so
he has some options here it's not all
about one simple decision and all of a
sudden arming the Ukrainians and why we
haven't done previously Peter the
pageantry of a of a summit can say a lot
about the nature of the relationship
between the two countries you know is
there state dinners they're not a state
dinner is there an address to Congress
what about the schedule that the two of
them have over the next day what does
that say about the relationship between
the US and Germany right now what it
says is that this was a business meeting
from the start Brendan and it's still a
business meeting only the business has
been escalated substantially she's here
private talks about four hours and all
she got here last night and then they're
gonna have a press conference they're
gonna air
whatever differences there may be in
public or they're more likely going to
smooth over those differences and
suggest that there still is unity this
is a president who has great respect for
Angela Merkel of all the world leaders
she's right there near the top of the
list in terms of someone that the
president looks to for advice and
counsel on things happening in Europe
and around the world they have a good
relationship that relationship will be
put to the test today we will see a play
out on camera yeah Peter into Brendan's
point of course they do have a good
relationship we can't forget that there
was this whole scandal over US
intelligence officers tapping the German
Chancellor's phone i wonder if at all of
that has been patched up peter go my
question is simply about timing are we
likely to see the president make a
decision today or will he wait until the
men's conference on Wednesday I can't
imagine that the president would make a
decision today in Lisa and that's the
information I'm getting from US
officials as well the president wants to
hear what angle and Merkel has to say
she met with Putin directly he wants
information before he makes his decision
remember you've also got the possibility
of sanctions out there as well as a
short-term step but it seems pretty
clear to me the president will at least
give Angela Merkel through the minsk
meeting before making any decision on
further army in the ukrainians the Peter
Cook thank you so much from Washington